[Music]
good morning John it's Friday August
17th no it really impressed me that some
nerdfighters are so in to Brotherhood
2.0 that they will in fact correct you
on your cat licking technique by showing
us how to lick a cat by licking a cat
however Katherine has pointed out to me
that to some cat owners licking a cat
isn't really a punishment in fact it's
something that they kind of like to do
Katherine sometimes will put cameos paw
in her mouth and I'm like she walks
around in the litter box walks around in
the litter box which is like piss craps
and
and then cameo walks on it and then
Katherine puts her paws in her mouth but
they're so cute they are very cute paws
I wish she was here she's not she's not
around right now I wish she was here I'd
show you her little paws okay I wouldn't
got her no good paws but I'm not gonna
lick her because I haven't been punished
and I hope I never will be punished
again because your punishment has set
the bar far too high
I've made a slight mistake and my
brother had to play no duties and that
is that I filled up my hard drive with a
video I'm making for eco geek and now I
can't make this video without finishing
that video but that videos gonna take a
really long time to finish so I have to
make this video but I don't know how I'm
gonna export it but I have to make a
video as brother do I know I have to do
it I have to do it okay
so we've all have been letting me know
about the problems that we're having
with the website I don't want to bore
you with the annoying frustrating this
of it all so I will just say that we're
working on it and that I don't know what
it will be fixed but until then I'm not
going to link directly to the wiki
people working on the week you can work
on the wiki and people who want to look
at the wiki can look at the wiki but I
don't want to look directly to it cuz
it's kind of resource intensive for
people to look at it okay I just want to
point something out here when I look at
the wiki can look at the wiki can look
at the wiki can look at the wiki don't
look at the wiki can look at the wiki
you think it's impressive that you can
say evil ladybaby when I look at the
wiki can look at the wiki John you might
not know this but when I look at the
wiki can look at the wiki if I keep
putting that could between everything I
say look at the wiki can look at the
wiki in my video we'll get much much
longer I'm gonna look at the wiki can
look at the wiki but the size of my
video won't get any bigger gonna look at
the wiki can look at the wiki it's just
the way that I movie stores files so
wanted to say that your birthday is
coming up it so I'd like to say that if
any nerdfighters want to email me about
a secret project please email me at hank
mt at gmail.com with in the subject line
the words secret project if you don't
put the word secret project in there I
will not get it it will end up in gmail
archive which is where emails enter but
they can never leave it will be there
for the rest of eternity email me about
viral marketing
it's about viral marketing John I will
see you on Monday and I'm looking
forward to it
when I look at the wiki can look at the
wiki I look at we can look at the wiki